- So he also took this video of you.
So I wanna play it.
This is pretty good.
- Well, I should certainly
let Your Majesty know.
Thank you.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- You can't understand what's happening
but basically, when we watch "The Crown,"
or any show with an
accent, I have to do it.
I can't not do it.
- Wait, do you repeat the line,
like, while you're watching?
- Every single time.
- You are my daughter.
- I cannot stand watching
movies with my daughter.
Every single line she
looks back and repeats it.
- Yeah.
- Like, as if I wasn't there.
- Right. Right. You know, is it just--
is it every line or just accents?
- It's every line, especially jokes.
- Her tick is different than my tick then.
- Okay. Okay.
- Mine is just accents.
So like "Game of Thrones"
with me, I don't recommend it.
"The Crown" with me,
I do not recommend it.
It is-- I recognize it
as, it's not diagnosed
but I'm sure it is some sort of a tick.
But I am mimic.
Something sounds funny in the air to me,
it falls out of my mouth.
And every now and again,
he grabs the camera.
- Of course.
- This is my life.
- 'Cause you look quasi crazy.
You got your bottle and
it's probably water,
looks like vodka, and you're like--
Everybody, I'm not kidding.
"The Woman in the House Across the Street
From the Girl in the
Window" is on Netflix.
You gotta watch it.
(audience claps)
It's so amazing.
It's funny but it's also just really good.
Anyway. Also, check out
Kristen's new line of premium
CBD skincare and bath
products called "Happy Dance."
That's awesome that's available now.